Paul Manafort faces the next decade in
prison after a guilty verdict for
multiple financial crimes a jury
convicted the former Trump campaign
Chairman on eight charges including tax
and bank fraud not tied to the campaign
the judge declared a mistrial on ten
other counts Paula Reed is outside the
courthouse in Alexandria Virginia Paul
oh good morning good morning
the jury could only reach a partial
verdict but this is still seen as a win
for Special Counsel robert muller and
his team especially after months of
partisan attacks on their investigations
integrity mr. Madoff would is
disappointed of not getting acquittals
all the way through Paul Manafort lawyer
addressed reporters yesterday after the
jury convicted his client on eight of
eighteen criminal counts
they include five counts of filing false
tax returns on tens of millions of
dollars in political consulting income
from rushing back to crane Ian's
officials manna fort was also convicted
of two bank fraud charges and one count
of failing to report foreign bank
accounts he is evaluating all of his
options at this point
mana Ford could spend the rest of his
life in prison sources close to the
investigation tells CBS News he is
banking on a presidential pardon
president Trump reacted to the verdict
after landing in West Virginia
watching
but man afford faces another trial later
this year in DC the charges in that case
include conspiracy against the United
States and acting as an unregistered for
an agent for Ukrainian interests and
Virginia Democratic Senator Mark Warner
a ranking member on the Senate
Intelligence Committee says that trial
could link the Trump campaign to Russian
interference in the 2016 election the
question will be as we move into this
next trial will MIT mister man efforts
start to cooperate with mr. Muller
this special counsel's office has not
probably commented on the verdict but
they will be back here next week to
announce whether they will retry Manta
for it on those 10 counts where the jury
could not reach a decision
Norah all right Paula thank you so much